vamos a empezar este vídeo platicando
acerca de los poliedros poliedros oye 2
muy bien un poliedro simplemente es una
figura en tres dimensiones donde todas
las caras son planas y todas las aristas
son rectas por ejemplo un cubo sería un
poliedro déjame pintar por aquí un cubo
un cubo tiene todas sus caras cuadradas
entonces quedaría más o menos así sale
imagínate que todos esos son cuadrados y
está en perspectiva algo de este estilo
y luego voy a pintar estas aristas que
quedan que quedan como por atrás vale
estas aristas entonces un jugo sería un
poliedro porque todas sus caras son
planas son cuadrados y todas sus aristas
son rectas aquí le voy a poner cubo pero
hay muchos más poliedros por ejemplo un
prisma rectangular también es un
poliedro un prisma rectangular está
formado dibujando un rectángulo otra vez
imagínatelo en perspectiva poniendo un
vértice externo y luego uniendo el resto
de los vértices con este vértice de acá
algo más o menos de este estilo esto
con este este con éste y éste con este y
finalmente este con este entonces s de
ahí sería un prisma prisma rectangular
rectangular
ocular y de nuevo este prisma
rectangular es un poliedro porque sus
caras son planas son triángulos y
cuadrados y rectángulos más bien y sus
aristas sus aristas son rectas bueno
pero lo que quiero platicarte ahorita es
la idea de red de poliedro o bien
desarrollo de poliedro déjame lo escribo
por acá nosotros le vamos a decir red
red del poliedro también se conoce como
desarrollo o como desdoble la idea es
bien padre básicamente si tenemos un
poliedro entonces podemos cortar algunas
de sus aristas y podemos desdoblar las
entonces por ejemplo con el cubo podemos
hacer lo siguiente déjame tomar este
cuadrado este cuadrado y ponerlo por
aquí lo voy a poner por aquí más o menos
entonces ahí tenemos el cuadrado vale
bueno pues si cortamos por ejemplo esta
arista y esta arista y también esta de
acá este cuadrado lo podemos desdoblar
hacia allá bueno solo tan solo con
cortar esta y esta podemos desdoblar
hacia allá vale entonces déjame pintar
eso con color
este cuadrado lo podemos desdoblar y
entonces podemos ponerlo por aquí
por aquí vale entonces ahí voy a poner
este cuadrado déjame hacer lo mismo con
la cara de atrás con esta cara de acá
esa la voy a pintar de color azul
clarito azul clarito vale y está también
la puedo desdoblar la puedo desdoblar
por esta arista que comparte con el
amarillo o por esta de acá que comparte
con el rosa déjame hacerlo con la que
comparte con el rosa entonces esta
arista sería exactamente esta arista de
acá entonces corto y desdobla para allá
vale entonces ahí pongo el cuadrado
y nuestro cubo se está aplanando verdad
se está aplanando baja déjame pasar a la
cara de arriba esta cara de arriba
comparte arista con la azul y con la
amarilla entonces podemos desdoblar
hacia acá y aquí nos quedaría un
cuadrado o bien podemos desdoblar hacia
acá hacia ella y nos quedaría el
cuadrado de este lado lo voy a poner por
acá vale es decir esta arista sería esta
arista de acá y aquí nos quedaría el
cuadrado y nos quedaría este cuadrado
voy a hacer lo mismo con el resto de las
caras voy a tomar el color morado para
esta para la cara frontal voy a
desdoblar por acá entonces esa cara se
va para acá que sería irse para acá vale
y finalmente voy a desdoblar la cara de
la derecha y lo voy a hacer en color no
se dejan usar este color en este color
rojo vale esta la puedo desdoblar hacia
muchos lados las juegos de doblar hacia
el blanco hacia el morado hacia el rosa
o bien hacia el azul para hacer las
cosas interesantes déjame desdoblar las
allá hacia el azul entonces nos quedaría
de este lado aquí nos quedaría este
cuadrado vale este cuadrado y bueno
justo a esta figura que ya es plana que
consiste en desdoblar el cubo le
llamamos la red del cubo o el desdoble o
el desarrollo vale tiene muchos nombres
y eso lo podemos hacer con muchos
poliedros lo podemos hacer con cubos con
prismas rectangulares vamos a hacerlo
con el prisma rectangular a ver qué pasa
sale entonces vamos a poner primero el
rectángulo déjame ponerle un color así
brillante lo voy a poner así color rosa
mexicano entonces ese lo voy a poner por
acá ese de ahí va a ser el rectángulo
muy bien este de ahí es el rectángulo y
ahora podemos desdoblar las otras caras
déjame desdoblar primero esa que no se
ve también esta que voy a pintar así en
color rojo que igual es un triángulo
vale entonces está desdoblando la hacia
allá me quedaría pegada por esta arista
y quedaría más o menos un triángulo pues
se ve como flaco verdad como así y como
así es un triángulo a cut ángulo va
ahora podemos desdoblar la de atrás a
ver qué sucede la voy a poner en color
amarillo la desdobló hacia allá es decir
por esta arista que sería esta arista de
acá nos quedaría un triángulo que se ve
más o menos así más o menos así
sale entonces ahí tenemos ese triángulo
desdoblado vamos con la cara de enfrente
que la voy a pintar con este color como
como morado claro entonces se va a para
cada
no sé cómo se llame este color a lo
mejor es púrpura casi nunca podemos
saber cuál es púrpura y cuál es morado
pero bueno vamos a decirle morado claro
entonces la desdoblamos para acá y
finalmente está la cala de la derecha
podemos desdoblar la hacia muchas
direcciones
podríamos ponerla por acá verdad y nos
quedaría ahí uno de los desdobles una de
las redes o bien podemos desdoblar la
por la cara amarilla y nos quedaría
entonces como como algo así verdad más o
menos pero déjame desdoblar la por la
cara morada entonces estoy doblando por
esta arista de acá hacia acá y entonces
nos quedaría el triángulo pegado pues
más o menos así más o menos así
sale entonces la idea es muy sencilla si
tenemos un poliedro podemos cortar por
algunas de sus aristas para desdoblar el
poliedro y que nos quede una versión
aplanada si lo piensas tantito esto está
padre porque entonces podemos hacerle al
revés verdad si tenemos las versiones a
planadas luego simplemente basta doblar
por algunas aristas para regresar a los
poliedros